ciò pone come questi ragazzi e benvenuti
a questo momento io sono tornati su
pubblicità giapponesi questa settimana
si preannuncia un episodio particolare
perché che ne so me lo sento
proviamo a festa ogni volta che porto a
registrare pubblicità giapponesino
dovrei guardare un qualcosa che a
scalare mi porti verso questo mood
perché se io dal da da 0 a 100 vedo
questa cosa e po come avere uno schiaffo
fortissima il ragazzo sto dori abituarmi
a questa roba e poi fare il commento
però fa niente ormai ci siamo dei
capelli
[Musica]
perfetto il rame di one piece la
milionesima volta ma teme l'uscita fatto
forza ma che dobbiamo fare giustini
ramin di quanti si sono impressionanti
dunque la benzina credo sia la marca non
vivere quando il rame
in giappone a questo punto c'è una
minchia il proraso voglio rivederla abio
cosa tensione lo vedi lo vedi lo vedi
overy lo prendi lo prendi indigeni
l'accesso mentre corri lo struscio ma
questa è poesia questa è poesia
giapponese afferma compagnia
marocchi e sapone ma rossi notte hanno
fatto sapere che a tomar o la
premiazione di madonna in italiano
parole uniche casinò bello alla birra
tory ma sto pubblicità delle br sono
sempre fantastiche uno che lavora ma
chiediamo con ernest aveva maria è però
ce l'ha chi rinnega strong bier che lui
si beve tuscany tuscany fermi questa era
la pubblicità più normale che io abbia
mai visto in giapponese
uno che lavora va a prendersi la birra
rileggo il barman esce è promossa
perfetto c'è questo per loro che cos'è
questo per loro niente perché il
confronto le altre poi volano i pist
rally con le gambe da maiale con la
faccia di pietro e per loro quello è
normale quindi questo qua per loro che
cos'è ecco appunto
io l'ho detto poi sembra che parlano a
cani ma ci rifaremo il 6 e il tono slow
modista tipo di sì ma mira correnti e
poi la pubblicità terranova ben 6
c'è una marcia vita ma cosa stiamo
parlando qua non sto capendo niente di
quello che sto vedendo la fa niente
gente che si fa i cazzi tua in vacanza
basta finito questa era la vicina ma
sarò sarai lavorativa
mi minore teme il 4 c totale sordità o
molto mosso tutto io non sto capendo i
nostri cari con i colleghi quando la tua
crush si avvicina addetti sussurra
nell'orecchio
stasera ho casa libera a casa libera
stasera sparkling ora questa cosa di
acqua
gianpi sei pronto
no però non sei pronto nonno che cazzo
sto vedendo ciao zio sisport this non va
bene
ah ecco perché se io no no se cazzo di
caramella luna basta basta basta
pubblicizzare ste caramelle all'uva con
prove che non c'entrano niente
dio mio capitano
[Musica]
fu christians o muori decapita si geli
cerca allora questa è stata l'unica
pubblicità in giapponese che io ho
capito dall'inizio alla fine perché non
era giapponese ma era in inglese e quel
e forse forse era meglio non capire
c'è questo aveva lo stomaco che
brontolava e allora gli hanno dato
questa cosa è una specie di gomma con
l'altoparlante perché cancelli e chi
copre il rumore dello stomaco che
brontola così dai compagni non ti
sentono lo stomaco
[Musica]
ma noi di cosa parliamo ma noi non il
bari non possiamo neanche compie noi non
siamo non abbiamo ne facciamo schifo
facciamo noi facciamo schifo si voto
valido saga si va in giro capito un
cazzo però va bene a musina un patatina
fuggono penso sia la birra credo madonna
che figata stanzia la donna deve copiare
un sacco lo stile questa è la stanza più
fidati abbia mai visto bellissimo
aspetta io durante la quarantena
perfetto neo antica e ed extremi questo
è il trailer di the trending per forza
di michele trasi del training noto
dall'agenzia dal dubbio condimento
panetta hanno messo la bocca hanno messo
le bocche sulla fanta per fare le facce
marketing del 2020 ragazzi marketing
basta ho finito clic clic bale
[Musica]
a perché e touch e noi che sia per quel
quid che va bene benissimo a capo come
nel caso essere su un'entrata da maio
poi attualità a pisa ancora quella
pubblicità della squadra di hiroshima
come si chiamano i karma my kart le
carpe dio c è ma stai calmo ragazzi
permetti io e lara tuo nonno che che sia
perché non ama c'è la verdura capito è
che i motori d'età e comunque la bevanda
degrado
ma fammi capire ma sono l'upgrade delle
pubblicità dell'altra volta cioè come è
possibile che ritornano sempre con dei
plus c'è questo è il dlc
vediamo comunque la piscina scorsa
l'itali schiaffi in testa questo basta
grand bleu fantasy certo cosa doveva
essere what he l'amato on
quinto il cazzo cosa c'era dentro cosa
c'era dentro
non lo so final fantasy che fa dai non
ho capito cosa c'era la dentro succo di
bill gates chiuderà ma non ho capito
indicato un po di quelle miste robot
final party ma non c'entra niente final
fantasy era dentro a caso final fantasy
ok pubblicitarie la macchina bellissima
che non avrò mai fantastico ragazzo di
appena detto dai cazzo non sono stupido
io ho sentite da ragazzo mi ha detto
quello buon appetito
no dai no ma che schifo
massimo
ma è narnia e narnia giapponese occhetto
posto comunque questa è la pubblicità
giapponesi il numero 1000 però non visto
anche l'ormai di farlo e ogni volta che
lo faccio mi viene sempre più voglia di
giappone quindi maledetto me che non ci
sono tornato però non potevo viste le
condizioni ragazzo oggi spero che vi
siate divertiti ci vediamo alla prossima
pubblicità giapponese la commentare nel
prossimo episodio iscritti da chiara di
schiacciata campane via privata
ragionato sui video e noi come sempre ci
vediamo al prossimo video bella ragazza
cominci va a destra è arrivato dai nas
[Musica]